chers compatriotes de métropole et
d'outre-mer de l'étranger
soir c'est avec au coeur l'amour et la
fierté de la france que je me présente
devant vous la france est une nation un
dante et indépendante
la france c'est une nation engagée pour
la justice et pour la paix c'est une
voix qui s'élèvent au dessus des
intérêts particuliers
la france mes chers compatriotes je
laime passionnément génie tout mon coeur
toute mon énergie et toute ma force à
son service à votre service servir la
france
servir la paix c'est l'engagement de
toute ma vie j'aurai voulu bien sûr
bousculer davantage les conservatismes
et les égoïsmes pour répondre plus vite
aux difficultés que connaissent certains
d'entre vous je suis fier du travail que
nous avons accompli ensemble fiers
d'avoir restauré avec vous des valeurs
républicaines essentiels comme le
principe de laïcité fier d'avoir conduit
des réformes importantes pour garantir
une retraite ou mieux aider les
personnes âgées dépendantes et les
personnes handicapées fier d'avoir
combattu sans relâche
l'insécurité j'ai fait reculer la
délinquance fier de voir les françaises
et les français engagés sur les chemins
de l'innovation et de l'avenir fier
surtout d'avoir montré que outre le
chômage
il n'y avait pas de fatalité même s'il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin
le chômage est au plus bas depuis un
quart de siècle
la france tient son rang la france
affirme sa place dans le monde et tout
cela c'est grâce à vous grâce à votre
talent grâce à votre créativité grâce
aussi et je le mesure bien aux efforts
considérables que vous avez consentis
mes chers compatriotes au terme du
mandat que vous m'avez confié le moment
sera venu pour moi de vous servir
autrement je ne solliciterai pas vos
suffrages pour un nouveau mandat d'une
manière différente mais avec un nom tout
dias mme intacte et la même passion
d'agir pour vous je continuerai à mener
les combats qui sont les nôtres
les combats de toute ma vie pour la
justice pour le progrès pour la paix
pour la grandeur de la france s'agissant
des échéances électorales
vous aurez l'occasion d'exprimer mes
choix personnels
mais ce soir est ou non de la confiance
que vous m'avez témoignée
je voudrais vous adressé plusieurs
messages
d'abord ne composait jamais avec
l'extrémisme le racisme l'antisémitisme
ou le rejet de l'autre dans notre
histoire
l'extrémisme a déjà failli nous conduire
à la bim
c'est un poison il divise il pervertit
il détruit tout dans l'âme de la france
dit non à l'extrémisme
le vrai combat de la france le beau
combat de la france c'est celui de
l'unité c'est celui de la cohésion
oui nos valeurs ont un sens oui la
france est riche de sa diversité
oui l'honneur de la politique c'est
d'agir d'abord pour l'égalité des
chances c'est de permettre à chacun à
chaque jeune d'avoir sa chance ce combat
malgré tous les obstacles et même si je
mesure le chemin qui reste à parcourir
il est désormais bien engagée il doit
nous unir dont la durée c'est l'une des
clés de notre avenir
mon deuxième message c'est que vous
devez toujours croire en vous et en la
france nous avons tant d'atouts nous ne
devons pas craindre les évolutions du
monde
ce nouveau monde il faut le prendre à
bras le corps
il vaut continuer à y imprimer notre
marque et il faut le faire sans jamais
brader notre modèle français
ce modèle il nous ressemble et surtout
il est profondément adapté au monde
d'aujourd'hui
si bien sûr nous savons le modernisée en
permanence
nous devons poursuivre résolument dans
la voie de la réforme en faisant
toujours le choix du travail de
l'innovation et de l'esprit d'entreprise
mon troisième message c'est l'europe
lors du référendum vous avez exprimez
vos doutes vos inquiétudes vos attentes
mais il est vital de poursuivre la
construction européenne les
nationalismes qui ont fait tant de mal à
notre continent peuvent renaître à tout
moment et ce n'est pas seul que nous
ferons face aux bouleversements
économiques du monde
la france doit être affirmée l'exigence
d'une europe puissance d'une europe
politique d'une europe qui garantisse
notre modèle social
c'est notre avenir qui est en jeu
portons toujours cet idéal et cette
volonté du quatrième message c'est que
la france n'est pas un pays comme les
autres elle a des responsabilités
particulières hérité de son histoire et
des valeurs universelles qu'elle a
contribué à changer
ainsi face au risque d'un choc des
civilisations face à la montée des
extrémismes notamment religieux la
france doit défendre la tolérance le
dialogue et le respect entre les hommes
et entre les cultures
l'enjeu c'est la paix c'est la sécurité
du monde
le même il serait immoral et dangereux
de laisser sous l'effet d'un libéralisme
sans frein se creuser le fossé entre une
partie du monde de plus en plus riches
et des milliards d'hommes de femmes et
d'enfants abandonnés à la misère et au
désespoir de voir de la france c'est de
peser de tout son poids pour que
l'économie mondiale intègre la nécessité
du développement pour tous enfin il y à
la révolution écologique qui s'engage
si nous ne parvenons pas à concilier les
besoins de croissance de l'humanité et
la souffrance d'une planète à bout de
souffle
nous courons à la catastrophe
c'est une révolution dans nos esprits
tout autant qu'à l'échelle mondiale
qu'il faut mener pour concevoir un
nouveau mode de relation avec la nature
et inventer une autre croissance avec sa
recherche avec ses entreprises avec son
agriculture avec l'avant ce qu'elle a
prises dans le nucléaire et les choix
résolu qu'elle a fait dans les énergies
renouvelables la france a tous les
atouts pour relever ce défi majeur du
xxième siècle
mes chers compatriotes vous l'imaginez
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion que je
m'adresse à vous ce soir
pas un instant vous n'avez cessé
d'habiter mon coeur et mon esprit pas
une minute
je n'ai cessé d'agir pour servir cette
france magnifique cette france que
j'aime autant que je vous aime cette
france riche de sa jeunesse
forte de son histoire de sa diversité
assoiffé de justice et dans vie d'agir
cette france qui croyais moi n'a pas
fini d'étonner le monde vive la
république et vive la france